outside of Ukraine and Russia Canada has
the largest Ukrainian population so it's
no surprise Millan joli was back in the
country offering a new kind of support
Canada and Ukraine will launch a new
International Coalition to bring back
Ukrainian children we will work with
Ukraine to help develop a consular case
for each child identifying and returning
illegally deported children has been a
top priority for Ukraine's first lady
exactly how many children have been
taken isn't known but it's believed to
be in the thousands children have been
used as props at Russian rallies
propaganda to support their claim that
the so-called special military operation
is rooted in Russia saving
ukrainians at campaign the Russian
defense minister toal's colleagues
included more than 120 strikes on
Ukraine last month alone strikes that
continue to be concentrated on
communities in the East Russia recently
floated the idea of creating
demilitarized zones in some areas it
occupies in Ukraine a red herring
according to the US if Russia really
wanted to show interest in a
demilitarized zone the thing they could
do is start by demilitarizing the parts
of Ukraine where they're currently
Russian forces on the heels of a
historic European Aid package which
Hungarian prime minister Victor Orban
stalled Oran said Ukraine will only get
weaker the longer the war drags on and
more people will
die Ukraine has no plans of giving up
and Canada was praised for its continued
support what can we say about Canada you
know everything about Canada Canada is
our closest friend since Russia's
full-scale Invasion Canada has pledged
more than 9 billion including two .4
billion in military aid Jolie's visit to
Ukraine did not come with more financial
supports Crystal ganing Global News
London